when you watch an event movie you want  to see it on the best screen you can you  want to be taken to another place and  IMAX takes you there like no other  format  [Music]  this is seeing JK Rowling's world with  this sort of Magna scale  it's been the most wonderful format  [Applause]  it is so vivid with visual and sonic  experience I am a huge fan because they  really understand filmmaking to ensure  that when a film is blown up onto high  max that it retains the beauty that we  put so much thailand loving care into  there was so much color and so much  vibrancy i've burn away by somewhat  out-of-body it's like you're in the  Wizarding World  I love the scale and experience of  watching everything on a massive screen  and with IMAX I feel like I am there  it's fantastic  [Music]  you  you